elle est aujourd'hui en rémission mais
doit encore patienter pour s'estimer
guéri cette maman de deux garçons
adolescents découvrent en novembre 2018
qu'elle est atteinte d'une leucémie un
choc
forcément puisque dès qu'on prononce le
mot leucémie égale cancer on sait que
tout de suite on sait qu'on risque de
mourir
donc oui c'est d'abord un choc en même
temps c'est un soulagement parce que moi
avec les maux de tête que j'avais
j'étais intimement convaincu qu'il ya
quelque chose qui tournait pas rond
hospitalisé d'urgence à l'hôpital mignot
de versailles fabienne entamé une
chimiothérapie 24 heures sur 24 pendant
15 jours les médecins ne lui diront
jamais que le pronostic est mauvais mais
ne lui cache pas qu'il faut procéder à
une greffe de moelle osseuse on
interroge le fichier international de
donneurs les gens qu'on appelle les
veilleurs de vie et heureusement que le
fichier est internationale parce que
malheureusement dans notre pays on
compte environ 300 milles d'honneur
alors que les pays comme l'angleterre
l'allemagne ont jusqu'à trois ou quatre
millions de donneurs il faut savoir que
trouver un donneur sur le registre
international c'est une chance sur un
million
un donneur miraculeux que les médecins
trouveront en angleterre fabienne ne
connaîtra de lui que sa date de
naissance mais fille unique elle
s'identifie très vite mon donneur rien
d'en parler forcément c'est assez
émouvant parce que c'est vrai que c'est
quelqu'un qui ne vous connaît pas du
tout qui fait ça sans savoir qui y va
était probablement qu'on lui a dit que
j'étais une femme que j'avais des
enfants
mais c'est vrai que oui du coup lui ne
connaîtra jamais mais moi qui n'ai
jamais eu de frère par exemple sachant
que maintenant c'est son sang qui
circule dans mes veines
donc maintenant j'ai son adn dans mes
veines
oui pour moi c'est un frère professeurs
des écoles fabienne de girardi n'a pas
encore retrouvé sa classe
aujourd'hui elle partage son expérience
pour appeler aux dons dans quatre ans
elle saura si elle est véritablement
guéri